Hey look guys my name is eterno and
welcome back to my state wealth wealth
series today I'm going to be talking all
about visibility in sip of blood so
visibility is really a concept that
belongs to object-oriented programming
and really what it refers to is how
visible certain members or methods of a
class actually are and what I mean by
visible is who can see them and who can
call them and who can use them and all
that stuff so right off the bat I just
want to mention that visibility is
something that has absolutely no effect
on how your program actually runs and no
effect on program performance or
anything like that it is purely
something that exists in the language
for you to be able to write better code
or to help you out with organizing in
code that is it so there are three basic
visibility modifiers that we have in C++
private protected and public in other
languages such as Java or C sharp there
are other keywords in Java for example
you can just not have a visibility
modifier and that's kind of called the
default visibility modifier in c-sharp
there's something called internal in
super boffo we just have three private
protected public that's it
so let's take a look at what they do so
in a class if I were to just define x
and y as two variables like this inside
a class called entity for example since
this is a class the default visibility
would actually be private meaning that
this code here would be the same as if I
had actually written private explicitly
though exactly the same thing is however
I write a struct then it would be public
by default so the fact that I've not got
a visibility written here doesn't mean
that it doesn't have a visibility it
does it's just that it implicitly gives
it one either public if it's a struct or
private if it's a class you want to know
more about the differences between
structure and classes I made a video
about that so click over here and you
will see it actually I think it's
probably over there run one so let's
take the special class
and leave these as private what is
private means private means this only
this entity class can actually access
these variables meaning it can read them
and it can write them now I should say
only
asterisk because there is actually
something called a friend in C++ it's
like a whole keyword and everything
called friend and what that actually
enables you to do is label a class or a
function
as a friend of say this entity class and
what a friend means is that a friend can
actually access private members from
classes we'll have a whole video on
friends in the future so don't worry too
much about that for now so if I just
define say a constructor here I can
assign X to 0 or something like that
however if I were to instantiate the
entity here inside main which of course
is outside of this class scope I can't
call yo X equal to or something like
that because it's actually it's private
if I have a sub class of entities that
here we have player which is a subclass
of entity if I have say a constructor
inside player I also actually can't
access X from here because it's marked
private meaning only that entity class
or friends can actually access those
variables the same applies to functions
if I add a function here called print
same exact thing like I can call the
function from within the entity class
like so that's totally fine however if I
try and do it from a sub class plushes
player or from a different place all
together like this I actually won't be
able to call it because it's private
ok next step up we have something called
protected there is no sane next step up
is because protected is a little bit
more visible than private less visible
in public so protected means that this
class of course there's empty class and
all subclasses along the hierarchy can
also access these symbols so you can see
that now I can totally do X equal to and
print inside the player club because
player is a soft passive entity however
I can't I can't do that from inside main
because it because that's completely
different function is outside of the
class it's outside of class and it's not
part of a soft class and then finally I
have public which of course means that
the access for all anyone can access it
I can access it inside the entity class
inside the black cloth which is an HT
and inside the main function which is is
it is something of its own so there we
go
that is the short answer TL DR or TL DW
I guess of what visibility actually is
in C++ now let's talk a little bit about
why you might want to use visibility
where you use civility why
you just make everything public yeah
what's the deal with that so first of
all making everything public is purely a
bad idea for the purpose of actually you
being a developer and writing code if
it's just a matter of style it's just a
matter of how can I write code that is
easy to maintain easy to understand by
people who are going to read this code
and maybe extend the code it has nothing
to do with performance nothing to do
with this will generate different code
absolutely not visibility is not
something that CPU understands is not
something your computer knows about it's
just it's just something that humans
have invented in order to help other
humans and themselves so when I say help
other cubans what I mean is that if you
mark something as private that basically
tells everyone including yourself hey
you shouldn't be accessing this from
another class right simple as that or
some other code you should only be
accessing this internally inside this
class what that means is that if I've
never used a class before in my life and
I look at what it contains I should be
able to say that okay I'm only allowed
to actually touch the public stuff
that's how I should be using the class
that's the proper usage of this class as
to actually is to actually call the
public functions if I'm using a class
that's part of an API and I'm I look at
it and I see a private function that I
want to call I know that I shouldn't be
calling that private function the author
of that class probably has provided some
other means to achieve the same thing
because if I if I were if I were able to
call that private function maybe that
wouldn't give me the result I expect or
maybe that would break something else
code is of course this whole like web of
complexity and by being able to specify
visibility we can ensure that people
don't don't call other codes they
shouldn't be calling and potentially
break things a great little example of
this is a UI let's just say that I want
to move the position of a button if I
just had access to the x and y of the
button and I change that variable the
button might not actually move I mean
sure the X and y position might be
different but in
the button to actually move suppose that
we actually had to refresh our display
well suddenly five is set X to five or
something like yeah the X variable has
changed but the display actually doesn't
know that it has to grab that a new
value from memory if it keeps using the
old one that it's gone however if I
create a method inside that class called
set position on set X I can do more than
just a sign X to what it needs to be I
can also call another method called
refresh or something like that that
actually does everything it needs to I
can make that X variable itself private
and then that set position or set X
function public and then clearly anyone
who wants to use this code and who reads
the code can see that I okay I shouldn't
be assigning ax directly I can just I
should be calling the set axe of the
deposition function so that's a cute
little example of why you might want to
use digital be all to help other
developers and to help yourself it's
amazing how quickly you can forget code
that you yourself have actually written
so don't think that okay I'm never
working in a team I don't need to I
don't need to deal with this disability
I've spent everything public no if you
look at your code in a couple months or
a couple weeks through and sometimes a
couple days you might forget how it's
supposed to work but by using something
as simple as visibility you might see
what your intended way of accessing and
utilizing this this class actually was
based on accessibility people argue
about visibility way too much on the
internet I don't really want to be one
of those people I do have my opinions
and my beliefs about where you should be
using private where should be using
public some people for example will
always write variables as private always
and then just have public getters and
setters I strongly disagree with that
whole approach especially be always part
because there's this always is almost
never attorney here in programming at
all it's almost always a point in which
you actually want to use something in a
certain way but I will save all those
arguments for future videos let me know
what your thoughts are about this whole
visit or everything where you use it why
you use it leave all that in the comment
section below and I'll see you guys next
time goodbye
[Music]
[Music]